welcome back to the Rich Eisen show to
you our listeners and viewers and also
the man to my right who's been on once
before and now he is back to talk about
city on a hill on Showtime it is a
terrific new show Sundays at 9:00
Eastern Time he's been in so many great
movies and television shows he is Kevin
Bacon good to see you sir thank you
thank you happy to be here this is not
your first Boston rodeo no Joe by a long
shot
no I do a lot of Boston I'm not really
sure what okay yeah I mean I've got I've
got just off the top of this card here
Patriots Day black mass Mystic River
yeah so you've got the accent down pat
well I don't know about that
down Pat's down nice little golf class
or so much you know you know I like to
say that if you're from Boston you're
never gonna like somebody doing a Boston
accent right people from Boston don't
even like people from Boston to emboss'd
on access he doesn't sound authentic but
I like that did sound off hahaha you
know it's weird because I'm from Philly
and and yet I it's maybe like the sixth
thing I've done there I met my wife in
Boston we fell in love in Boston so it
has a lot of fun fun place in my heart
and alright I really like working there
you know and one of the good things
about being able to work actually in the
city is that if you are trying to do a
Boston dialect which is not the easiest
one in the world you're surrounded by it
because the guys are gonna pick you up
at the hotel and drive you you know
especially you know all the Teamsters
you know they're sure they're gonna have
to be the real deal so just put your ear
to the ground and absolutely and then
you get going yeah yeah so I mean so how
how often had did you shoot in Boston
shot the whole thing there we shot the
whole the pilot and the last episode
some of the you know it's 1992 and
interestingly enough there's a lot of
parts of of Yonkers and of Staten Island
look a little bit more like Boston the
Boston you shot it
my hometown yeah that yeah yeah we shot
quite a bit in Staten Island we shot in
Brooklyn we shot a lot in Yonkers so so
you know it just ended up making more
sense so when when you were in Boston
was it during any sort of well I mean
you could choose any damn time of the
year and it's championship time lately
in Boston sports were you there during
this World Series run no we were there
it was we were actually there what we
were there for is like the the biggest
snowstorm in Boston history or something
like that it was a it was I guess
February of love 2018 or and I can't
even remember about a year ago we got
completely dumped on and just kept
shooting you know there's no there's a
great scene in the pilot where I'm
talking to the course award character
played by Aldous Hodge and in the
background words in front of this big
you know kind of plate glass window you
just see this crazy storm going on
outside there was a Spore extra that all
night had to walk back and forth be like
holding the Sunbrella and you you as we
sat that we literally just saw the snow
go like this but I can tell you that
when we were going back for the final
episode there was a real roll of the
dice because a lot of the location had
all to do with the Stanley Cup Playoffs
because if if that if the boroughs are
won a lot of our locations would be not
good because they would the parade would
have been going by or whatever so
everyone was like huh consistently you
know the poor production matters you she
couldn't care less about hockey but
she's constantly watching they just
trying to figure out where where our
locations are gonna be and it was it was
it was it was interesting it was amusing
I mean I think it would have been fun to
be there if they won well I mean it is I
guess you know and I'll give you he's
from the New England area dr. Kevin
Chris Brockman over there I'll give it
to you it's just it's difficult to shoot
these days in Boston because you never
know if there is a parade that's gonna
mess with your shooting schedule these
Devery so you're from Philly did you
grow up liking Philly sports or London I
did not I grew up I've kind of a weird
relationship to sports where as a kid we
didn't I didn't really play any
organized sports I'm really kind
terrible athlete we played a lot like
right on the street because I grew up on
the street and we would play we used to
play a game called the half ball which a
lot of people I say you never play
happily what's half ball well in the
streets are so small in Philadelphia
that you take a regular what we call the
pimple ball and you cut it in half and
then you hit it with a broomstick so
it's like kind of a version of baseball
but you're only using half a ball so
that doesn't go very far because
otherwise you lose it on somebody's roof
or in the gutters or whatever and you're
actually allowed to get somebody out by
throwing the ball and hitting them
that's and and it's you know the ball it
doesn't bounce in any way that's an
aside but that being said I was not I
was not much of an athlete or and I also
wasn't our sports fan because I was so
deeply into rock and roll and and and
frankly rocking along with girls and
that I just didn't really have this the
sports bug at all when I moved to New
York in the 80s I became friendly with
Ernie Grunfeld who was playing for the
next Knicks and then a future general
manager of the Knicks right future GM
and started to go to the next games well
Bernard King and him that was the Bernie
and Ernie show right exactly when
Bernard King was lightening up 50 points
a night in the state of Texas right one
particular January in the middle of the
decade right I remember these moments
Kevin yes you do obviously obviously
yeah but you know that was my
introduction really to even being into
sports at all okay ed but what a great
time because going up up through that
time into the 90s and and and that that
team and and you know you know Starks
and Ewing and Oakley and Anthony Mason
and so so that so now i i i i feel a
strange you know I have a strange
loyalty about Philadelphia teams and a
lot of people find this really annoying
but if a New York team is not doing well
I will very easily root for Philadelphia
team like I was very excited about the
Eagles and
very excited about you know how far the
Sixers got this year and you know so I
I'm kind of like a split personality
Kevin Bacon here in the Rich Eisen show
so you can understand how long it was
for Philadelphia Eagles fans to wait for
that moment two years ago to get that
World Championship and you also know
what it's like to be a Knicks fan to see
what the hell's going on with that
franchise right now isn't amazing that
the Nets are maybe the team in New York
right now it's to God that we were
talking before just the makes me feel
old I said I texted a friend of myself I
feel old when I go I can't believe that
two of the hottest teams are the nets
and the Clippers I'm just like yeah I
don't know why it makes me feel old but
it makes me feel a lot but ya know I
listen and I think it's I think it's
great you know I think it's exciting I
think I think I think actually that
there's right now there's a lot of
really exciting talent in the NBA in
like this last playoff series I was
riveted and you know not by obviously
not by teams and I hear they weren't
around but except for Philly but but you
know I think it was it's it's it's a
cool time to be watching the NBA yeah I
mean Phillies got a great chance with
embiid and obviously the team that they
put out there dude I think he's I do too
I think he's awesome
I really like that guy I love to watch
him play I know and I just I love the
fun that he has you know I know you're
on Twitter at Kevin Bacon I don't I lack
active you are but he's just a dynamite
follow is it yeah he's funny the stuff
that he'll just tweet out and then you
know obviously when he had he had fun at
the the Raptors expense a little bit and
celebrating and then he kind of caught a
little bit agree for that but I remember
that one yeah he did like an airplane
sort of maneuver and as we all know they
lost that they lost that series in
Toronto roads you're right I mean there
were so many great talented players all
over the lot and it seems like
everything is a little bit more
competitive now with the Warriors all
banged up and yeah you know moving on
all right Kevin Bacon here on the Rich
Eisen show so two of the you know I'm
sure you're asked this all the time I'll
ask it anyway Affleck and Damon are they
do you you guys go way back do you know
that at all
no no they call you for this I mean
how'd you get involved on a hill did Ben
Affleck had an idea as far as I know for
for this show and he related to a young
writer that he knew and had had I guess
work with before I'd been developing
something named Chuck McClain and Chuck
is a really kind of brilliant young man
with a incredible for his age incredible
sense of boston history and of american
history and in general and and also
films and he's one of the it's one of
those guys that you know i just go man
your hard drive is big because it's just
the amount of information that he can
hold there and and he has a great
he writes beautifully and then he took
this idea of benz and just ran with it
and then showtime came to me and i sat
down with the director and with chuck
and you know when I read when I read it
it this project seemed to drop out of
the sky a little bit which makes me
always think who fell out I always think
to myself
did they have did they have that just
you know got indicted or whatever and
you know I mean how did I get this gig
but after all this time it goes through
your head oh yeah man yeah I mean it you
listen I'm always shocked at anybody you
know that's to give me a good gig
anymore I mean you know I I just felt
like the part was was so juicy that I
sort of thought to myself wouldn't
wouldn't everybody want to play this guy
but I don't know maybe some people are
scared of this kind of material well I
mean you're awesome and a jakir or the
FBI agent who I'm hoping has a little
bit more good in him and what I've
already seen so far and sitting on okay
there's a few stories that have been
written about you would some of your
quotes that are in them I want to make
sure that these are true we you always
play celebrity true or false here in the
rich oz I would like to do that here
with Kevin Bacon here on the Rich Eisen
show please hit it Mike del Teufel
interesting we have you here since
that's from a scene that you were in it
if you go that was all right first one
up here is true or false is it true that
you tip DJ's at weddings you attend to
not play the song Footloose I have done
that yes and I'll tell you why I haven't
dude would you like to hear my reason
for that Kevin Bacon the floor is yours
thank you I believe that or a wedding is
the one day in a non celebrity's life
when they can be the star of the show
okay the stars of the show are the bride
and groom the supporting cast is
bridesmaids and the parents and you know
the best man and the maid of honor all
that I don't want to make a wedding
about me it's like that's the one time
when it should not be about about the
famous person in the room so when that
song comes on what happens is I could be
out on the dance floor enjoy myself
first of all the song doesn't come on
let's face it until there's been a lot
of alcohol so people have been super
super cool and kind of like I'm not
going to invade his space but at the
point 10:45 when this jockey decides to
everyone is half in the bag
and it comes on and people will form a
circle around
it's like the hora
yeah but I'm supposed to perform you
know like uh you know a trained monkey
and I so what's the going rate to grease
the deejay well it's been a few years
okay it's probably it's probably gone up
you know III don't think a twenty we cut
it oh my gosh alright next one on that
next one now you based your characters
hairstyle and Footloose on sting because
you're a big fan of the time of the
police yes that's true that's true now
that being said I I said that that's
what I was kind of going for well I mean
if you really
look at me through the years and you my
hair has always been pretty much related
to stinks I was such a big I was such a
big fan of the police and but this
haircut yeah was given to me by a
hairstylist for the screen test for
Footloose and the haircut cost $1500
they told me this this is 1982 so that
was a lot of money and the true story is
while I was sitting there going home I'm
getting sorry little crap I'm getting up
a $1,500 haircut I look up and the guy's
got his eyes closed come on
he was cutting my hair he was supposed
to be a user genius guy I think he had
one name and there he was just like this
and you know whatever
the rest is oh my gosh then if you will
movie history movie is next one for you
true or false Kevin Bacon you work for
only four days on the set of JFK yeah
that was true yeah it was yeah it was a
quick one yeah
four and out yeah for and out and but it
was it was it was a pretty intense it
was an intense four days I mean I would
say that they were spread out over
probably over like three weeks or
something like that so it was it wasn't
like I just went and shot them all
together right but yeah okay and what
what days were what other scenes were
being shot when you were there well
there were just your scenes there were
some times when not some other stuff was
going on I think one of the one of the
things that I was amend reminded of the
other day just coincidentally I ran into
Kevin Costner who was in the in the in
the movie and he was remembering that we
shot a scene at the Louisiana State
Penitentiary which is a out of another
era it's a massive massive plantation
prison I mean I don't it's like 10,000
acres or something like that and
bordering it is this giant swamp and
there's no there's no wall because
no one has ever made it through this
swamp right because it is so rife with
alligators and snakes and mosquitoes and
everything that gets I get up you can't
you can't cross it and we were doing a
scene if you could picture back behind
me is the swamp and I'm sitting on a box
or something and Kevin's sitting over
here and we're doing my coverage so the
cameras are facing this way and there's
some guys in the background who are
extras and I think there were actual
prisoners that they were that they were
using and they were supposed to be back
working like in the swamp I know cutting
weeds or something like that and I start
doing my my scene and Costner is not he
keeps looking past me and he's like
distracted and I'm thinking wow um you
know I'm trying to do my best here and
this guy's not even listening to me you
know he's no he's not you know watch me
I was really getting pissed and they
said cut and turns out a guy was getting
attacked by a snake and and he had a
machete and was like going chopping
through the through the swamp trying to
get rid of this snake and I ran into
Costner the other day he said listen
dude I'm so sorry
I hope you know like that's a lot of
years later he had remembered it and so
and I frankly not during the take I
didn't know afterwards I they afterwards
I think he had said listen you know
somebody was there was something going
on there was a brouhaha a turkey shoot
with the snake yeah that's amazing all
right last one for you here you were
cast in Animal House while still in
acting school and flew it first class
for the first time coming out to LA
that's true fact yeah yeah I was still
in acting school I was probably about 18
and the casting director came to circle
in the square I wasn't in a acting
school and said we need this kind of
type and they sent me over there and I
got the part yeah and you got it and
what was what was Belushi like oh man he
was funny
generous and just a you know just a dine
and he's the first
star that I had ever met my life you
know so he was already a big star on SNL
right SNL was was already such an iconic
thing to us in I guess in New York but
also beyond and I'll never forget he he
had a put he was doing he was doing
Saturday alive at the time that we were
shooting Animal House so he would spend
I guess Monday Tuesday Wednesday and in
Oregon where we were shooting and jump
on a plane and get back for Thursday and
then work until Saturday and Sunday come
back so it's a crazy crazy schedule but
at one point he found the time we were
all in this you know crappy hotel on the
side of the highway but he had a house
and he had a party for for us for the
cast told was there there was no time
that would be fun mandated ask ya know
no there's no toget but this blew my
mind because there were two things one
well few said one is that I said wow
this guy can afford to throw a party
that blew my mind
number two he had bought smoked salmon
like from Zabar's or from Barney
Greengrass or something all the way out
to Oregon from New York City Nova and I
first off to me smokes it like Nova was
so expensive that I wouldn't even eat it
at that point in my life because I
couldn't afford it it was and they were
pot they're just piles of it I was like
oh my god I got to put this in my pocket
and and the third the third thing was
that it was the first time I'd ever
tasted or heard of him a mosa and the
idea that you would take orange juice
and mix it with champagne with like the
most expensive thing that you could
possibly order and you're just gonna put
it in champagne and would put it in
orange juice and then just drank it in
the morning I was like this is so cool
I really want to be a superstar and have
mimosas and throw a party and AB smoke
Sam as much smoked salmon as anybody
could eat LOX for everybody that's right
mission accomplished you know what I
never thought Kevin Bacon and I'd ask
you that story able to hear about
partying with flounder having
there you go I'm done that's like a mic
drop Congrats on city on a hill it's
awesome thanks but it really is and
everyone should check it out Sundays at
9:00 Eastern Time at Kevin Bacon on both
Twitter and Instagram great to see you
sir
thank you come back any time yeah we've
just scratched the surface pretty much
with Kevin Bacon finish up the rest of
the show and set up the rest of the week
when we come back for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app